vous êtes si doué pour donner de l'amour que le plus
difficile est de recevoir de l'amour dr.  c'est Diana qui
raconte que j'ai déjà été tellement frappé par certains
hôpitaux me fascine je suis sérieux
ça ne me traite pas comme une princesse c'est
presque comme s'il ne savait pas qui je suis
peut-être qu'il ne le sait pas tu pourrais être très  mal
informé
je te connais je suis la fille à qui tu allais
demander un rendez-vous
je pense qu'il était je pense que c'est celui de
la femme la plus célèbre du monde qui
fait partie de notre famille
j'ai essayé de rouvrir des portes et
toi  Je leur ai tiré dessus, tout le monde pense que j'ai
foiré, nous étions trois dans ce
mariage, il y a donc beaucoup de monde, vous n'avez pas
foiré parce que maintenant vous serez libre,
vous êtes la femme la plus célèbre du
monde, c'est votre talent et votre pouvoir.
je peux tout faire je suis chirurgien
je ne peux pas travailler avec les paparazzis qui
me collent leurs caméras au visage quelqu'un doit
faire quelque chose si je me marie je dois aussi épouser
le monde entier
juste je n'arrive pas à choisir de ne pas dire que
c'est fini oui  - oh tu ne peux tout simplement pas le voir
et Sauveur
[Musique]
toi